welcome to the show I am back from my
emergency appendectomy which I will talk
about more a little bit later but let's
get into the news if you somehow
believed that the Ukraine whistleblower
is just a total liar or a plant someone
that can't be trusted
even though Donald Trump has already
confirmed a whole bunch of what the
whistleblower said there is now a second
whistleblower that is in the process of
coming forward in a world where Donald
Trump wants us to think everything is
fine we have yet another set of
blockbuster allegations potentially
coming forward from another
whistleblower related to Ukraine and
understand that the second whistleblower
is also an intelligence official and has
as far as we know right now first-hand
knowledge of the Ukraine Fiasco
involving Donald Trump now how far we've
fallen that in the past we'd say oh a
whistleblower from inside the Intel
community this is someone we should take
seriously in the Trump era one of the
most maligned areas has been the
intelligence community where the
president has successfully primed his
defenders not to believe anything we
hear from the intelligence community now
there's an important point to make here
before we continue the American
intelligence community has done many bad
things in the past and mostly they have
been things Republicans have liked
importantly but that's an aside right
now this is not about defending the
Intel community as a political apparatus
lots of right-wingers even some on the
Left say we should hate the Intel
community because it's been terrible for
decades and when you allow the
intelligence community some kind of
elevated status to tell us who is
behaving okay and who is not you are
essentially giving over political policy
to spies and that's not something we
want to do now there are lots of that
that makes sense there are many
political disagreements to be had with
the intelligence community's actions in
the past CIA and Latin America I mean I
don't even need to do the list but this
is a
attacking the credibility of individuals
and the work that they do which is
mostly motivated by wanting to do the
right thing at the individual level
which gets us back to her story because
there may even be more than two
whistleblowers at this point check this
out this is a tweet from andrew
because-- who represents whistleblowers
from the intelligence community who said
intelligence community whistleblower
update I can confirm that my firm and my
team represent multiple whistleblowers
in connection to the underlying August
12 2019 disclosure to the intelligence
community Inspector General no further
comment at this time
multiple whistleblowers could be - could
be more now the president immediately
writing this off as the actions of the
deep State the President of the United
States is no longer even pretending to
be anything other than a blatant
conspiracy theorist tweeting quote the
first so-called
secondhand information whistleblower got
my phone conversation almost completely
wrong not true by the way
so now word is they are going to the
bench and another whistleblower is
coming in from the deep state also with
second-hand info meet with shifty keep
them coming now Trump mentions shifty
which is his nickname for Adam Schiff
head of the House Intelligence Committee
and this is the new attack strategy from
Donald Trump the first strategy was the
deny deny deny that didn't work then the
strategy became well say that there was
nothing wrong that happened even though
you did talk about Joe Biden and most of
the material details that we got are
actually accurate even by your own
admission say everything was fine now
it's well they are all left-wing
democratic deep state plants controlled
by Adam Schiff and Trump's attorney Rudy
Giuliani who himself by the way should
be a target of these investigations
tweeting very much on the same page
quote surprise Democrat lawyer has other
secret sources swamp media will
corruptly failed to point out it means
nothing now that conversation is public
no money no quid pro quo unlike Biden
helping son make millions from Ukranian
crook orchestrated dem campaign like
Cavanaugh listen these people are not
well ok these are truly sick people and
we can do political analyses up and down
every single day but the political
analyses fall short because in a sense a
political analysis assumes that we are
dealing with well people which we are
not we are now going to get a chance to
see just how blind and bamboozled Donald
Trump supporters are and here's the big
story it started with one whistleblower
on Ukraine one on the IRS which you may
not even have heard about we now have a
second one on Ukraine all within two
weeks just imagine how many pent up
potential whistleblowers there are who
have seen incredible illegal things the
trumpets are doubling down on this is a
democratic hit job it's all fake and we
showed you the transcript of course the
transcript is only a portion of the call
and is already terrible for them and was
already reportedly a precondition of
Ukraine investigating Biden and
promising this deliverable so what the
trumpets have as their strongest defense
is to pretend that the transcript is
exculpatory when in fact it is a damning
piece of evidence and once again imagine
what we will know in just another week I
want to tell you about one of our
sponsors called the Menlo Club immense
fashion community that provides
carefully curated style packages for any
type of guy and they're giving you as a
David Pakman show viewer your first box
for $35 off when you click the link
underneath this video or go to their
site and use the promo code Pakman as a
member of the Menlo Club you receive
delivered right to your door a
hand-picked apparel package that follows
the seasons latest trends based on your
own unique style
profile I hate shopping for clothes it's
always been a pain to go to a store
figure out what to buy and that's why
the Menlo Club is so perfect for me all
I had to do was fill out a quiz on their
website so they could learn my sizes and
style preferences and then I received
clothes that perfectly fit my own
personal style so far I've really
enjoyed what they've sent me all of
their clothing is designed by their team
in Los Angeles
each box features items from their own
in-house fashion brands 5 for everyday
wear New Republic Footwear and Grande
see athleisure wear in every box they
send you you get a minimum of two items
often more every box is different
shipping is always free and they let you
exchange what you get if it doesn't fit
you can pause or cancel your
subscription at any time right now I am
on their monthly subscription for 60
bucks a month but they also offer a
seasonal subscription where they send
you a box of clothing every three months
for just 75 bucks but regardless of
which option you choose they are giving
everyone in our audience $35 off their
first box to redeem your $35 discount
just click the link under this video or
go to their website and use the promo
code Pakman at checkout